PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
This week, we're
talking about supercomputers,
magic buttons, and the smartest
$100 you ever made.
Welcome to This Week in
Cloud, where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
This year alone, job listings
requiring Google Cloud skills
shot up by 65%.
And our Professional Cloud
Architect certification
was named the top-paying
IT certification.
As if you needed any
more encouragement,
we are rolling out the cloud
certification challenge.
Earn your certificate within
12 weeks of signing up
for the challenge,
and we will give you
$100 in Google Store credit.
To make it even easier,
you'll get free access
to courses on
Qwiklabs and Coursera,
as well as tips on
taking the exam itself.
Well, what are you waiting for?
Our ability to generate
data is starting
to outpace our
capacity to process it.
But it won't for long,
thanks to EXAScaler,
an in-cloud system that
Google recently developed
in partnership with DDN.
This is big news
if you're running
a high-performance
computing application
or planning to build anything
AI-intensive in the future.
Read the post to learn more
about the unique benefits
of using EXAScaler jointly
with the Google Cloud Platform,
and see which industries
stand to gain the most.
Then, try it out.
There's good reason to
love event source systems.
But we noticed there weren't
any off-the-shelf solutions
for getting one up and running.
So we built one.
This guide walks you
through the why and the
how of bringing an event
source system into being,
and how to tackle
some key challenges,
like keeping messages in order,
creating a schema registry,
and triggering workloads
based on published events.
Check it out.
If you regularly work
with sensitive data,
you know how important data
loss prevention tools are.
Adding the ability to access
those tools seamlessly
from within the GCP
services, like BigQuery, just
makes sense.
Introducing the Scan
With DLP button--
by using Scan with
DLP, you'll be
able to detect common
sensitive data types,
create triggers for automatic
DLP scan scheduling,
publish reports for
further analysis,
and even obfuscate
sensitive data,
and all without
leaving your database.
If you value data
protection and compliance,
and you love pressing
buttons for a worthy cause,
try out Scan with DLP today.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.